[Applause]
[Music]
we may not like it but we can't say that
corruption in argentina
as in most countries is anything new the
truth is that since the first government
meeting back in 1810 virtually no
argentine government has been free of
suspicion
the possibilities are almost endless and
the incentives are
very very generous and don't think it's
just a matter of sticking your hand in
and you're
done because most corruption cases are
far more convoluted than this
however what has been uncovered in
recent years it does
go much much further we're talking about
the realization that in argentina there
has been a systematic process
led by the nation's own government with
the object of looting the country's
public treasury on a far
larger scale
and we're not talking about the
occasional bribe but billions of dollars
that given the evidence seemed to have
been stolen during the perinis
governments of nestor kirchner and
christina fernandez to kirchner
more news comes almost daily but the
goal of this video is to tell you
how it all started what happened and how
this plot worked a plot which the very
presidency of the republic was involved
in as well as dozens of politicians
judges
officials and many of the most important
businessmen in the country
folks this looting operations plot known
as the notebooks began with the arrival
of nestor kirchner in may of 2003 and
continued under the presidency of his
wife christina fernandez de kirchner
until 2015. that is to say the
systematic pillaging of the public
coffers happened for more than a decade
now before we look into what this
consisted of and
how much money it meant for the
argentines we have to answer some
questions
about the real protagonists of this
story the kirchness
we need to look at who they are how they
got into power and how they managed to
set up what is perhaps the biggest
operation in the history of stealing
from argentina's public coffers so
listen up
[Music]
the kirchner's ascent
two provincial politicians who managed
to own argentina for years so it all
began with a beautiful love story
between two
young university students nesta and
christina met
in the mid-70s while studying at the
national university of la plata in
buenos aires
love soon bloomed and in 1976 after the
military coup
led by lieutenant general jorge raphael
videla our two lovers decided to
leave and work as lawyers in the city of
rio gallegos in the province of santa
cruz
a city by the way that is far away from
the capital indeed it's more than 2
650 kilometers away
if we had been asked about that couple's
particular future at that time we
probably wouldn't have mentioned
anything about national politics however
after democracy returned in 1983 this
nice lawyer couple joined the perinist
party and it was their folks that
the career of those who became
argentina's underwoods really began well
now that we actually think about it was
probably the underwoods who became the
kirchners of the political series it was
a relationship
made by and for power first in 1987
nestor kirchner was elected mayor of rio
gallegos and a few years later in 1991
governor of the province of santa cruz
then finally
in 2003 he became president of the
republic of argentina
[Music]
and during this time christina fernandez
didn't stay
on the sidelines she made her career in
the legislative chambers
as provincial deputy national deputy and
national senator until in 2007
she arrived at the presidency of the
republic and then in 2015 she went back
to the senate
yes it seems like the kirchen has had it
very very clear between the legal
profession and politics
politics more than 30 years of living
off taxpayers certainly something of a
career
however just a moment here
[Music]
the province of santa cruz which is
where the kirchners began their
political career
isn't only far from the capital which
after all is the center of power but
in 2001 its population didn't even reach
200 000
inhabitants it was about 0.5 percent of
the country's entire population which
at the time was approximately 36 million
people
so how did two politicians from a place
that is
so far from the core of power and so
small
take control of the entire country this
is the question that many journalists
and political analysts have been asking
for a long time
well now we're beginning to unravel the
answer basically this husband and wife
duo took over
co-opted and bought almost every sector
of argentinian politics
through the power of their wallets
[Applause]
unionist judges journalists artists and
civil society leaders succumbed to the
power of the state's wallet it was
billions of dollars distributed among
the pockets of those who supported and
were unconditional supporters of this
peculiar marriage a clientele network
fed and greased by concessions aid and
subsidies that were conveniently
distributed and which
nobody controlled however the question
that we have to ask ourselves is how did
they finance it how did the kirchners
maintain such an ample wallet
well listen
the goal of public work
[Music]
look at what christina fernandez said in
for us for this administration public
work isn't a contingency
it's a conviction a structural political
concept that we've been developing
not only since 2003 but since we gained
the responsibility of directing a
community's destiny
christina fernandez de kirchner well now
we know why public works were so
important for this marriage
and no i'm sorry but it has nothing to
do with argentina's interests
public work was one of the core parts of
the kirchner's political fabric first in
the province of santa cruz
and then throughout the entire country
now some of you might be wondering well
simon
hold on a second how did the system
actually work well you'll see that deep
down
it was actually quite simple president
kirchner through his minister of federal
planning and public investment
julio devido who stayed in this post for
the entire period in which the kirchners
headed the country met periodically with
the main construction companies in
argentina which in turn
were convened by the president of the
chamber of construction carlos wagner
well in these meetings it was agreed
exactly which company would get each
public tender that is essentially they
were meeting to decide how to distribute
the cake
[Music]
then when everything was decided the
tender procedure actually started but
this was simply for mere appearances the
company which was chosen was the one
that this kind of public works cartel
had previously agreed upon
and now comes the key to the entire
process
once the work was granted the companies
charged the first installment of the
contract the
advance payment they needed to
supposedly begin working however this
payment was given
entirely to the politicians
so hold on a second where was the
business if these companies had to pay
back
what they charged well that was in the
extra costs
see it's estimated that on average each
project's extra cost ranged from between
30 and 40 of the total bill that way if
work was granted for 100 million budget
expansions were approved
for up to a total of approximately 140
million but that's not all sometimes the
government would also approve
changes and new project expansions until
the company that had been awarded the
100 million dollar work ended up
charging
a lot more 180 200 250 million and even
up to 2.8 times the initial budget so in
this example
280 million and to top it all off many
of these projects
they weren't even finished yep you heard
that right of course in exchange for
this bargain companies paid bribes to
politicians depending on the case
between 10 to 20 percent of the invoiced
amount having said that have you ever
wondered how public work functions
in your country the thing is that this
thing worked perfectly
for years but now well it's been exposed
argentina
[Applause]
[Music]
the little details really counter when
one doesn't take care of all the details
even the most complex and ingenious
operations run the risk of collapsing
this case was not an exception
see it turns out that the driver who
transported the government's bribe
collector was obsessed with writing down
each trip each stop each building
visited the name of the people he was
going to see for the briefcase delivery
even the conversations he heard
during his travels he'd written down
practically everything
in eight notebooks we don't know if he
did it on impulse for entertainment if
it was part of a kind of control and
accounting system or perhaps he simply
wanted to cover his back
the reality is though that these
notebooks contain all the details
of this mafia plot
and finally those notebooks came into
the hands of a journalist who upon
seeing what they contained decided to
turn them over to justice
and after months of investigation at the
end of july 2018 high officials and
businessmen
linked to this plot were arrested but
that's not all now many of these people
have decided to collaborate with the
justice department
in exchange for benefits such as not
being in prison while the process
continues
and one of those individuals is carlos
wagner the president of the chamber of
construction
the man who called the companies and one
of the people who benefited most from
this entire mess his story confirmed
everything the notebook said
and the other testimonies they went in
the same line but right now
i'm sure you might be wondering well all
right simon but how much money are we
really talking about here well the
reality is
it is a ton of money see if carlos
wagner is telling the truth the
kirchners would have received
almost 3 million dollars a day
and they did that for their entire 12
and a half
years in government that is more than 12
billion dollars in total
and that's only from the public works
besides just the public works there are
many more suspicions of corruption and
pending cases
[Music]
they essentially got 12 billion to pay
politicians judges
journalists social leaders and of course
fill their own pockets
everything indicates that this is how
the kirchners came to power and
consolidated that power over argentina
for example there's also jose lopez's
case a former public works secretary and
someone who was very close to
giulio devito the kirchnerist minister
who managed the plot well in june of
2016 having been alerted that the police
could raid his house as part of an
investigation he decided to leave at
three in the morning with nine billion
dollars that he had in cash
hidden under his mattress anyway that
night lopez tried to hide the money in a
convent the convent of the praying and
penitent nuns of
our lady of the rosary of fatima but
this didn't have the best of luck
while he was stashing the money a
neighbor who thought that it was a
robbery
called the police and that's how good
old jose lopez was caught red-handed and
yes we know where all that money
probably came from
[Music]
by the way as you can imagine this money
couldn't simply be transferred to a bank
no it had to be paid in cash so it
wouldn't leave a trace it was moved
in bags well since they made so many
payments the people in charge of filling
the bags already knew
how many money wads fit into each bag so
it seems that the money was no longer
counted in millions but
simply by number of bags
by the way do not forget that companies
also made money by overpricing so the
damage to the argentine people has been
even greater
anyway dear viewer this is the gruesome
story of how some politicians decided to
plunder their own country if the facts
are confirmed even the underwoods would
be scandalized by argentina's situation
so will christina fernandez end up in
jail
well only time will tell so i really
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends at reconsider media they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is made
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]
you